one of the on dramatic moments in the
HBO series and I think there was even a
YouTube video this was um people
watching the red wedding and what
happened just eaten the the video of
people watching that became viral were
you surprised that that's the entry
point that a lot of people made into
both the series and to your work I was
surprised by the videos I was not
surprised by the reaction to it because
I'd been through a similar reaction when
the book came out of snorosaurus
thirteen years prior to it
I remember one tweet that someone posted
the day after the red wedding episode
aired that said now you know why your
nerdy friend was really depressed
thirteen years ago and and there was a
certain amount of truth to that I got
letters at that time saying you know I
hate you I threw your book across the
room
I'm never gonna read you again I threw
your book in the fire that was a good
one because it was I threw your book in
a fire and then three days later I went
out and bought a new copy because I had
to find out what happened next but now
we were talking about millions of people
reacting to it
the red wedding was brutal in the book
but in some ways it was even more brutal
on TV because David and Dan the the
showrunners did turn it up to 11 by
adding the Talisa character and her
unborn child who don't exist in the book
rob is married but he has a different
wife and she's not pregnant and he
doesn't bring her to the wedding he says
now it's gonna be dangerous here so he
sends he keeps her at Riverrun where he
knows she'll be safe so by including her
they they made the scene even more
brutal which I think increased the
reaction to it even more but the most
astonishing thing was those videos to
fit the fact that people who knew what
was going to happen actually set up
their their wives and husbands and
children and parents and brothers and
sisters and friends and loved ones to
capture their dismay and shock at the
moment that that wedding hit was
something I never could have had
Cepeda that I don't think anyone did but
it was pretty amazing and a great
feeling yeah yeah it's it's you know
when you're when you write when I write
anyway I want to I want to engage my my
readers emotions or my viewers emotions
you you don't want you know death death
is a big thing you know when when we
experience death in real life
it affects us you know when when a
spouse dies or your parents die your
brother dies your dog gets run over or
god forbid one of your children dies
rips your heart out it affects you
emotionally if we're creating characters
that we really care about we should
react in a similar way when they die in
in fiction and we're on television it
shouldn't be just so okay that
characters dead let me go out and get a
sandwich during a commercial I mean then
and you're not doing your job I want and
I want to grab hold of my readers and
make them cry and make them grieve and
make them laugh as well and experience
joy experience the worlds on the page as
if they were living them that's the
dream of me at least and I think most
writers pop culture has grabbed Game of
Thrones it's been featured in The
Simpsons and South Park what do you like
us to remind when you when you see these
references and what happens well I think
it's tremendously cool
of course it's it's nice to be doing
something that everybody is so aware of
and that has entered the cultural
zeitgeist in that manner the only aspect
of it that really astonishes me is not
that the characters and the story is
being parodied or referenced in these
various places
what did extent that which I personally
am I mean when I see myself as a
character on South Park or I see Bobby
Moynihan imitating me with the
suspenders and the Hat on Saturday Night
Live when I see companies selling
Halloween costumes
not Halloween costumes to be John Snow
or Daenerys but Halloween costumes to be
me
that's pretty freaky that's something I
could never have anticipated and I still
don't know what to think of it cuz